the push for these radical unpopular
usually weird kind of sex policies from
the top from the established Elite
keeps getting more and more extreme the
latest video from old Nick's Pub which
is the Eugene Oregon venue hosting a
child drag show featuring a performance
by an 11 year old child and free
admission free admission for kids 10 and
under used to be there was ladies night
at the bar and ladies would get in for
free and they'd get cheap drinks because
then the men could hit on the women well
now our cultures moved past that now we
have kids 10 and under night at the bar
and presumably that's for exactly the
same reason this is the bar that we're
talking about
women Invaders and demonic forces waged
across the land upon a Mountaintop the
powers of the Ethereal Overlord and the
Demonic savior Goliath on holy views of
light were met with a laser glass and
demonic Flames were met with ethereal
blades
as defeat propel them the leader from
their Skies kneeled to submission and
was impregnated righteously
infected with the Sea Of The Dark One
the Fallen leader Lee decimated and
besieged inside of black and blue there
a parasitic fetus throbbed and thrived
all right I think I've seen 74 by the
Insidious so you see in this I mean you
can hear the the narration going on all
this demonic satanic talk this kind of
weird occult alternate history of the
world and then the imagery on stage is
just a dude dressed up like a demon with
devil horns uh doing all sorts of things
of people and kind of all sorts of
satanic imagery the pentagram and all
the rest of it now they're going to be
some people out there who are a little
less culturally minded who are not you
know maybe they're not all that
religious and and they're going to say
oh you know look is this weird yes is it
wrong to let kids into a drag bar yeah
that for sure isn't but when we're
talking about the imagery Michael come
on isn't it are we really going to have
another satanic Panic here I mean does
it does this really matter yeah it's
dumb it's weird but is it really evil is
it really so bad do we care I mean it's
all just kind of Make-Believe and
pretend and just silly and random isn't
it there are a lot of people who hold
that view
and my question then always is
if it's if it's all just so silly and
random if it's all meaningless if these
symbols don't have any meaning
why is it always the same symbols that
we're seeing why is it that the deputy
monkey pox coordinator for Joe Biden
wears the very same symbol that you saw
in that satanic image
why he always wears the the pentagram
and he has a not only a pentagram
leather harness on that he photographs
himself wearing he also has a pentagram
tattoo on his pectoral muscle
why is it that uh Biden's
energy advisor nuclear energy advisor
Sam Brinton dresses up in all these same
kinds of weird leather
occult demonic sort of things why is it
that when you see the pro-abortion rally
and the transiting the kids rally and
all the crazy colorfully haired uh
radicals who are hoisting The Pride
progress flag and they always look the
same and they've got the same kinds of
why is that and why does it always seem
to come back to the devil why is it that
Saul Alinsky when he wrote Rules for
Radicals the most important book for
leftist organizing in America probably
in a hundred years why is it that in the
acknowledgments he mentions Lucifer and
he says you know I've got to mention
I've got to acknowledge here the devil
who lost himself heaven but won himself
a kingdom
why is that
why
why do the same images which are the
images that have cropped up the same
symbols that have cropped up for all of
human history why are those the ones
being used
and I think the obvious answer is
because symbols represent something
the symbols represent a symbolized so
yes they dress up in their stupid
outfits and with the horns and they've
got this the stupid pentagram on the
wall but why are they doing that because
the that physical representation is
pointing to a metaphysical reality
that is evil it's just evil it's bad and
we can't we can't just throw our hands
up and write it off and say well you
know look
some people like images of angels and
cherubim and God and and some people
like images and symbols of the devil and
the pentagrams and the transit and it
just it's so it just so happens that the
people who go to church on Sunday and do
their jobs and get married and have kids
and take care of their family and I want
a good country and vote almost always
for the conservatives and don't want to
destroy our entire Society those guys
always just really like the kind of nice
Angelic imagery and the people who want
to kill the babies and trans the kids
and open the borders and destroy our
country they for whatever just
coincidence So Random such a coincidence
they're always the ones with the satanic
imagery
I think it's a little more than
coincidence I think really when you get
down to it politics is not about some
weird kakamamie five-point ideology that
was cooked up in 1752 and now that's all
politics means forever and ever no I
think
politics is about do you want to do good
stuff
or bad stuff do you want to promote
truth or do you want to promote
falsehood do you want your society and
your country to be beautiful or do you
want it to be ugly like that drag bar
that's now luring children in so that
creepy men can prey on them what do you
want what do you want we have
political rights okay and for a long
time the conservatives we we just kind
of talked ourselves into this insane
idea that actually you know we don't
have any right to stop this stuff you
know if Google if Google wants to rig
the election well by golly we just have
to build our own Google but we have no
right to stop them from censoring us and
promoting all this terrible stuff and
suppressing all this because we we do we
have rights that's what political
freedom is that's true in the whole
anglo-american tradition it goes back
much further than that too
that's the idea that Edmund Burke talked
about this
the Great
the great conservative philosopher
he said you know
there is there is an exalted Freedom
Beyond just titillating yourself
Beyond just asserting your individual
appetites and desires there's a more
exalted Freedom that that finds that
that Liberty even in servitude itself at
times when we are recognizing that we
are in a community we have obligations
to one another and we don't want to live
in a country that's transiting all the
kids okay that is what conservatives are
waking up to in America that's what the
Trump movement was about that's why
Trump he didn't run on the slogan make
taxes low again
make killing babies and chopping off
genitals a private decision again okay
he didn't run on that on that week week
kind of pseudo right-wing
pseudo-conservatism that has been dead
since the early 2000s and that Britain
just learned because they tried to push
it again with Liz trust that's that's
not going anywhere okay either either
our society is not going to remain
neutral it's not going to have stasis
we're either going to move toward a good
country we're either going to make our
country great again and our civilization
great again
or we're going to go to that bar with
all those kids and all the demons in
Eugene Oregon the choice I I think Still
Remains ours it's an uphill battle
because of the disconnect between the
established powers and the actual desire
of the people but the polls show it we
can rest assured the people are broadly
on our side it is simply up to us to
assert our political rights now you know
it's music Monday I'm so very glad to be
here for music Monday the producers have
chosen
assault I don't know anything about this
song or this musician but I'm going to
give you my absolute
highest most sophisticated pop cultural
analysis you know I'm Wonder Mike and
I've come to say hello I'm I'm a rap
Mogul A hip-hop Maven I'm just a culture
vulture baby the rest of the show is
continuing now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
foreign
[Music]